thank you
[Music]
all right you guys do you guys remember
Ninja Turtles the movie the first one
absolutely the movie is still incredible
I could still cry watching just the
Splinter scene by the fireplace yep dude
when they're when Leonardo's or when
Raphael's in the bathtub I'm like yeah
yeah do you guys remember how Shredder
um I'd like to say died but he hasn't
died absolutely remember how he goes at
the end trash compactor yeah but then he
goes
yeah yeah dude you bust out yeah that
was like the thing after that I remember
and maybe it was cartoons first but I
remember everything had that thing where
the arm sticks out afterwards yeah that
started by
um the Deliverance I heard that that was
delivered like the first Ninja Turtles
one okay
recollection it's all started by Ninja
Turtles that is how our generation is
right or like every generation is like
oh that is from our thing yeah and then
like when when they like the kids are
doing tick tocks right now with like
Richard Pryor jokes and [ __ ] yeah and
it's like that's not their joke yeah you
can't use that so yeah occasionally
anyone hasn't seen it at the end of
turtles one Shredder falls into a trash
compactor truck and then uh Casey Jones
Goes oops and hits the crush button and
then it just slowly
um and he survives unlike this 19 year
old kid to do it dude what a setup god
dude Ryan is good I'm like my child came
out like the kid is alive and then the
kid just [ __ ] found death right now
it's a little harder to survive that in
real life uh even if you have ancient
Samurai armor on this kid uh I say kid
because he's 19 but he's an adult but
really this is like a really unfortunate
thing that happened to guide
Pennsylvania they've first of all
they're like how the hell did this
happen they ended up seeing surveillance
of this guy
um coming back from like a night out and
he might have been drunk he's like kind
of walking along this alley and then for
some reason he just gets into a dumpster
like and sleeps yeah and he's in there
for hours and then he gets crushed and
then a truck comes picks a dumpster up
loads it into the uh back good guy and
then just crushes him oh my God yeah
this is how he wakes up
yeah that's that's literally exactly how
it happened and really crazy that's
probably one of the worst ways to go for
sure yeah I mean because if you think
about it imagine like getting unloaded
and then you kind of realize you're not
in the dumpster anymore and there's
nothing you can do and then you just
hear the hydraulic presses go
um
makes me go oh yeah we're [ __ ] taking
the stick trying to have him stop trying
to stop it from getting crushed that's
what I think of dude this is how deep
and layered stair Wars is so uh I saw
There's a comic book out about that
particular garbage scene and about how
remember Luke Skywalker is getting
pulled under by that monster yeah well
apparently that monster was trying to
communicate with him using the force
really that's how [ __ ] deep and
layered Star Wars wow what was he trying
to say I don't [ __ ] know it's like
unbelievable how lazy the [ __ ] Disney
buying Star Wars has gotten yeah they're
like trying to make everything even
deeper it's like when Luke went up those
stairs it's like wait it's actually
about those were stairs from Tatooine
that got shipped to the Death Star it's
like
are these all fan fit things or is it
Canon like me Canon comic book [ __ ]
wild dude people are wild out there it's
pretty funny just come up with some new
stories for [ __ ] sake they're gonna do
some kind of [ __ ] social activism
[ __ ] in Star Wars
I like that though just saying and
door's good what's kind of interesting
about this and how like he was alone and
guys were staggering around goes in the
dumpster dumpster gets loaded he dies
um so me being sober my whole life I've
always imagined like you know when I'm
the person that takes care of the drunk
people because everyone's [ __ ] drunk
and I in my head I imagine [ __ ] like
this happening I'm like damn when people
go like oh take care of my friend
they're drunk some people go take care
from how and I'm like because if they
just [ __ ] go off on their own they're
not thinking the most random Final
Destination [ __ ] could just happen yeah
you don't remember when trash day is
yeah you go off and to spice I will say
though crazy
the decision on whether or not to sleep
there yeah is all dependent on trash day
yeah yeah just getting so hammered that
you go into a dumpster though is like
that's drunk that's a move it's a move
he likes to party come on I don't want
to say like you deserve it because
that's the worst thing to say so I'm not
gonna say that you're telling me you
think this kid has a drinking problem
I'm not gonna say that
can you edit it so it just sounds like
you said he deserves it
he's asking for it he's asking for it
dude what was he wearing
have you been so drunk that like every
time you blink you're in a different
place
that's why I don't drink holy [ __ ]
that's why I don't blink it's a hard
time every time you blink you're at a
different place yeah like I was like
boom I'm in the garage boom I'm in my
bed boom I'm in the shower boom boom
you're somebody's in your butt basically
and then the next morning my mom's
telling me I was pissed in the trash can
and [ __ ] the pillow and then she's
like she always called my pillow my
girlfriend
and that affects that affects you how
old are you have it happened 14 14.
that's probably 14. you could end up in
a [ __ ] dumpster [ __ ] the pillow
are you gonna bring your girlfriend to
dinner tonight
introduce me to the lovely uh what is
your name
Simmons silly yeah my pillow was my
girlfriend for me it's a great roast
they were all going to sleep with your
girlfriend
dude yeah yeah cause she said like um I
told the story tons of times but we got
drunk in the garage before they came
home and I thought it would be fine but
you in the pillow me my friend we were
drunk and then um when my parents came
home they all scattered and bounced and
I was just like puking my guts away on
the driveway they brought my dad
basically carried me threw me in the
shower like they they rinsed me off and
obviously I was naked so then they put
me in bed and I started [ __ ] the [ __ ]
out of a pillow and they're just like
what the [ __ ] and I got up and I pissed
into a trash can and I went back and I
started [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of a pillow
hey if you're gonna piss somewhere
that's not the toilet all time remove I
think yeah it's a trash can yeah some
people like [ __ ] open drawers and
piss on their [ __ ] clothes and stuff
you know what's some other crazy [ __ ]
you've seen actual drunk friends do
other than like [ __ ] themselves you've
seen a friend [ __ ] himself that's right
himself oh he's wearing white pants
because
after Labor Day because when you're
hosting the party somebody's gonna help
clean up you know oh no you have to do a
little poopy [ __ ] went down to bangoria
oh yeah that's right Gloria where the
[ __ ] is that it sounds like is that like
wakanda
so hey it's where we used to live it was
all kenja's house I remember in high
school this is kind of mean but it was
funny at the time we had a friend who
like he'd always talk about how much he
could drink all the time we were
probably like 16 17. I didn't drink and
I was always the sober guy and [ __ ]
because I was a wuss and this dude he it
was like he was like dude I'm gonna get
so [ __ ] up tonight bro it's gonna be
crazy we're like all right bro I was
sick whatever he [ __ ] uh takes like
three shots of whatever the [ __ ] by like
9 p.m he passes out on a chair and he's
just a [ __ ] drunk mess and he's just
thrown up everywhere
we drove with him so we're like [ __ ] we
got to take them back like whatever so
he kind of ruined the night for
everybody so we we brought him back
and he woke up in the morning and then I
was like Yo dude like you [ __ ] missed
out do you remember anything
[ __ ] no idea and I was like dude you
got your dick sucked and I told him that
he got his dick sucked by some like
random chick and he was like dude like
like that's sick like he was like really
hyped about it well you'd even know and
we just kept pumping him up and it just
became a whole laugh between the whole
friend group and we're all just like
dude you're the guy that gets his big
sub bro like we literally fed up
something like that and he was like [ __ ]
yeah bro like that's I'm the dude I'm
that guy he's like dude I get [ __ ] up
and the chicks come over start sucking
my dick he's like I can't really
remember it dude
and then and then like a week later I
was like hey dude you never got your
dick sucked like shut up about it and
like that's that's what I did yeah I'm a
piece of [ __ ] dude that's actually
pretty great yeah yeah it was funny it
was kind of funny you really took care
of him he had to pay yeah down in Austin
when me Bart and Geo were just we had a
show out there and then they took us to
a club we were just like Austin like
that Sixth Street or whatever they go
[ __ ] wild dude like we're in this
upstairs part this guy comes out of the
bathroom this girl just [ __ ] making
out she goes down and just rips his dick
out and starts sucking everyone's like
what the [ __ ]
yeah that's a while see could have
happened
all that sounds exhausting when you hit
a certain level of 30s you're like
there was a really funny situation it's
like legendary with uh my friends
because we were in some [ __ ] City God
knows where this was I think it was
somewhere in Canada this uh me and my
friend were hanging with these two girls
like for the night he got really sleepy
decides to go to the hotel room to you
know knock out and then the me and these
two girls are hanging out though other
girl's like why'd he go to bed like
where's your friend tell him to come
back I was like he's he's probably
asleep but you know what he loves
he loves when girls sneak in his room
and just start sucking his dick
he's gonna [ __ ] love it so it's okay
so I go into the room this one girl like
me and her friend are both egging around
to do it we're like yeah
crazy
stroke so he's [ __ ] knocked down in
his bed she goes under the sheets like
leg side like they do in scary movies
and [ __ ] and then me and her better
we're just in my bed just like it's like
a two bed [ __ ] room so we're just
looking like this and then you see him
go
oh
and then like the deed is done and then
the next morning
so the lights were off this entirely he
doesn't even check who's sucking his
dick
complete could have been a [ __ ] ghost
the lights are off the whole time the
next morning I'm like hey uh do you even
want to see a picture of this who this
girl is or anything he's like
nope he never so to this day every time
I ask him I ask him like every year it's
a mistake I'm like hey before I lose
this picture of her do you want to know
who it was and he's like no wow it's
been like 12 years wow I know oh you
know like that was you
not even my friend was behind it because
it could be better I want to know so I
could be like thank you that was a
really nice morning exactly can I buy
you breakfast that was [ __ ] awesome
yeah he does be grateful because we did
a lot of things that day so it's hard
for him to like even like narrow it down
but he wouldn't he wouldn't have thought
like you know they they were hitting it
off and everything he just got sleepy so
he has no clue I thought she's just the
most agreeable chick in the world yeah
unless items like it very trolley nature
very gullible it would be like exactly
annoying me nobody wants to know yeah
that's a could be some Gallagher looking
dude